[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález nuestro tema de
hoy nos lleva hasta medio oriente a esa
nueva escalada de tensión y ataques
entre israel y el grupo hamas en la
franja de gaza- las partes ya han
acordado un alto el fuego luego de 11
días de confrontaciones
la decisión la tomó el gabinete de
seguridad de israel pero también
funcionarios de hamas confirmaron que la
tregua sería simultánea y mutua la
comunidad internacional había pedido
desde diferentes voces el cese el fuego
inmediato esta semana precisamente el
secretario general de la organización de
naciones unidas antonio gutiérrez
manifestó su preocupación por la
situación e hizo un recuento de los
hechos recientes con énfasis en las más
de 240 víctimas palestinas y la decena
de víctimas que habían dejado también en
el lado de israel
estoy profundamente consternado por los
continuos bombardeos aéreos y de
artillería de las fuerzas de defensa de
israel en gaza para el 19 de mayo se
habían cobrado la vida de al menos 208
palestinos incluidos 60 niños e hirieron
a miles más and in your house mismo los
continuos disparos indiscriminados de
los cohetes de hamas y otros grupos
militantes hacia centros de población en
israel que causaron al menos 12 muertos
incluidos dos niños y cientos de heridos
también son inaceptables y soso en
excepto mi corazón está hoy con las
víctimas y sus seres queridos los
combates deben cesar de inmediato
fighting + stop y me hago un llamado a
todas las partes para que cesen las
hostilidades ahora no la metieron y
llamado a toda la parte para un alto el
fuego inmediato los fallos
y los combates han dejado a miles de
palestinos sin hogar y han obligado a
más de 50.000 personas a abandonar sus
hogares y buscar refugio en escuelas
mezquitas y otros lugares con poco
acceso a agua alimentos higiene o
servicios de salud
a vos unified valorizaron los informes
de que nueve miembros de una familia
murieron en el campo de refugiados de
shati if there is
si hay un infierno en la tierra es el de
la vida de los niños en gasa o hyundai
según la organización de naciones unidas
unos 75 mil 700 palestinos han sido
desplazados por estos ataques 47 mil de
ellos están refugiados en 58 escuelas de
la agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados en palestina en medio oriente
es decir en la zona de la franja de gaza
otros 28.700 están con familias de
acogida ahora sólo quedan las
consecuencias de todos estos ataques las
agresiones los desplazados las víctimas
todo esto en medio de la pandemia de
kobe 19 para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a marcos peckel él es director
de la comunidad judía en colombia se une
a esta conversación desde la capital
colombiana a la ciudad de bogotá y
también desde buenos aires en argentina
se une a este diálogo el imán marwan
will el ex presidente de la comunidad
musulmana ahmadía en argentina y también
es coordinador del
revista revue religions para la región
de suramérica les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar todos sus preguntas o
comentarios en las redes sociales en la
recuerdo estamos en facebook y también
nos encuentran en instagram y en twitter
como france24 bajo ese i arroba sant y
luego pueden dejar todos sus comentarios
a partir de este momento pues comienzo
entonces preguntándole a marcos en la
ciudad de bogotá sobre este ese es el
fuego anunciado por las partes se puede
ver este ese es el fuego como duradero
con la ayuda de egipto y también con la
presión que hubo por parte de la
comunidad internacional cuál es su
opinión
marcos le recuerdo que debe activar el
micrófono para poderlo hoy porque no le
estamos escuchando ahora sí muy buenas
noches a toda la audiencia de france 24
alemán en buenos aires y a ustedes
gracias por la invitación primero que
todo quiero decir que él
y el título del mensaje que se está
dando es erróneo este no es un conflicto
entre israel y palestina este es un
conflicto entre israel y hamas y ya no
está peleando acá con la población
palestina está pegando con una
organización terrorista cuyo objetivo ha
sido desde su fundación la destrucción
de israel no es un órgano organización
que ilegalmente ocupa la franja de gaza
porque expulsó de ahí al gobierno
legítimo de la autoridad palestina en el
año 2007 y desde entonces se ha dedicado
únicamente a cumplir con lo que dice su
carta fundacional la destrucción de
israel
eso se puede leer ahí ahí está
claramente por lo tanto hay que aclarar
los términos
es buena noticia que hay un cese al
fuego pero si jamás sigue controlando la
franja de gaza si no permite que retorne
el gobierno legítimo estaremos
simplemente en una ronda más de otra que
habrá porque jamás se dedicará a
reconstruir toda su infraestructura
bélica no le importan los dos millones
palestinos que viven bajo su dominio y
entonces estaremos en un tiempo no sé
cuánto otra vez viene una ronda como
este señor will su opinión sobre este
ese es el fuego será duradero
si ante todo a salam aleikum salami la
pasta con ustedes creo que obviamente
para empezar es una buena noticia el 6
en el fuego pero considero que no es la
resolución no es la solución para el
conflicto en el medio oriente sino que
simplemente tenemos ahora quizás si los
israelís podrían de nuevo volver a la
normalidad a vivir de nuevo con más
seguridad pero creo que para los
palestinos va a seguir la vida que ellos
siguen viviendo hace décadas que es un
estado que ellos en un momento un estado
que sus derechos sus derechos básicos
son violados si vienen constantemente
con discriminación o con persecución y
para ellos no se cambia mucho no cambia
mucho su situación y creo que eso es
también en ese sentido después
seguramente van a desaparecer un poco el
enfoque desde el occidente sobre el
conflicto pero lo que es importante
aclarar que ese conflicto sigue viniendo
hace 70 hace casi siete décadas y la
situación para los pero esti nos va a
seguir así hasta él
las comunidades internacionales o no y
todos los países no establezcan la paz
basándose en la justicia la clave para
realmente resolver este problema es
resolver el conflicto en una forma de
decisiones mutuas pero basándola en la
justicia y mientras no haya justicia no
podemos resolver ese conflicto y sería
solamente
por de poca duración hasta que brote la
próxima o el próximo conflicto que es lo
que la historia nos ha indicado que
estas escaladas de tensión entre las
partes comienzan de un momento a otro y
sucede en cada cierto tiempo entre ambas
partes
me gustaría que con ustedes analizaremos
precisamente ese el cese el fuego
alcanzado por israel y hamás después de
estos 11 días de enfrentamientos que fue
lo que pesó más o más acá en esta
situación el diálogo planteado por
egipto la presión que ya estaba
ejerciendo la comunidad internacional
sobre israel y sobre hamas o esa
diplomacia blanda que instauró el
presidente joe biden y que en cuatro
oportunidades habló directamente con el
primer ministro benjamin netanyahu y en
un momento le dijo por favor cese el
fuego de inmediato comienzo entonces la
ronda a la inversa por el señor will
sí creo que eso esa vez fue algo muy
interesante que creo que fue más la
presión internacional y también esta vez
creo que normalmente esta vez fue lo que
hubo en ese contexto que por las redes
sociales más gente estaba consciente lo
que está pasando en palestina a muchos
de nosotros de ser occidente no estamos
familiarizados con todo el sufrimiento
con todo el malestar que están
padeciendo los palestinos hace décadas
incluso esta vez a varios diplomáticos
académicos políticos de eeuu
abiertamente criticaron a su gobierno y
pidieron a una una una crítica una
condena hacía los ataques de israel un
ejemplo muy recientes del senador bernie
sanders él dijo por ejemplo abiertamente
que lo que está pasando
y lo que está haciendo planeta y hay un
no es solamente defender a su país oa su
estado sino que el cultivo una forma de
gobierno nacional o una forma
nacionalismo racista y dijo que es lo
que está haciendo es una conducta
antidemocrática y racista luego tenemos
informes de varias organizaciones
humanitarias que no son gubernamentales
que ellos también abiertamente
condenaron criticaron las decisiones los
ataques del estado de israel por ejemplo
un ejemplo a human rights watch y
amnistía internacional el director de
amnistía internacional salil y gas y
abiertamente condenó y dijo que incluso
tenemos evidencias de posibles crímenes
de guerra por parte del estado de israel
y en ese contexto creo que fue más la
presión internacional que llevó a ese
punto del censo del fuego y señor peque
el cual en su opinión israel se dio ante
esta presión internacional que piensa
usted de los argumentos que daba el
señor will
yo no creo que se trata de ceder ante la
presión internacional creo que sí hubo
presión internacional como la viento de
los conflictos y guerras cuando hay
víctimas pues especialmente en el
conflicto palestino-israelí que es el
que más atención atrae tanto en medios
como en organismos internacionales todos
opinan y realmente creo que se llegó ya
al punto donde ya no había nada más que
hacer creo que jamás
un horrible error de cálculo cuando
decidió comenzar esta ronda de manera
irresponsable otra vez poniendo a su
población en riesgo cuando decide lanzar
cohetes a jerusalén la capital de israel
sea ningún país del mundo tiene porqué
soportar que ataquen su capital de esa
forma y lo hizo con una excusa
absolutamente inaceptable porque los
acontecimientos que están ocurriendo en
jerusalén son recurrentes cada equis
tiempo lamentablemente hay
enfrentamientos en jerusalén la plana de
las mezquitas y sin embargo jamás
dada la cancelación de las elecciones
palestinas de córdoba que presidente
mahmud abás fue elegido el año 2005 para
un período de cuatro años se lleva a 16
en el poder y va a haber elecciones en
junio de este año y al ver las encuestas
seguramente prefirió cancelar las y
jamás aprovechó esa coyuntura para
comenzar una guerra con israel
pero más allá del conflicto con israel
su conflicto con los palestinos con la
autoridad palestina con abbas lo llevó a
comenzar una guerra con israel para
marcar puntos en la opinión pública
palestina de una manera irresponsable de
manera realmente que puso en peligro
como se vio a la población de gaza que
es rehén de esta organización desde el
año 2007 y ahí es donde vemos que
realmente jamás se organiza que yo tengo
un interés ni en la paz ni en una
convivencia pacífica con israel su carta
fundacional lo dice destruiremos a
israel y dentro de esa filosofía se
enmarcan todas las actividades de hamas
da bienvenido el cese al fuego ojalá
dure pero si jamás sigue en control de
la franja de gaza si sigue usando la
ayuda internacional que recibe en vez de
utilizarla en la población la utiliza
para construir fábricas de misiles o
para traer misiles para una próxima
ronda pues habrá una próxima ronda la
diplomacia de egipto siempre ha sido muy
importante en estos casos y creo que fue
la diplomacia más efectiva en este caso
más obviamente eeuu que poco a poco fue
presionando a israel para cesar él fue
el fuego
si incluso también alemania envió a su
ministro de relaciones exteriores jayco
más a israel para que conversara allí
con el primer ministro de israel
benjamin netanyahu para tratar de bajar
un poco el ánimo entre las partes y pues
ya vemos que no necesariamente ese
diálogo arrojó resultados sino que la
conjunción de los diferentes factores
que ustedes están mencionando la presión
internacional la presión de eeuu el
agotamiento de las tropas y también pues
también la situación sanitaria que se
está viviendo a nivel internacional
señor wil en cómo evalúa usted las
repercusiones que va a tener esto para
las partes que claramente ustedes ya han
empezado a mencionar algunos puntos
claves en los dos países o los dos
territorios
hamas y palestina e israel están en
coyunturas políticas particulares israel
no tiene un gobierno formado palestina
tiene unas elecciones aplazadas y esta
división de poderes entre cisjordania y
la franja de gaza
como ven ustedes entonces que queda la
situación interna
allí a nivel político después de el
agotamiento que dejan estos combates sí
creo que eso hay que aclarar que como
ustedes al inicio indicaron que no hay
nada ningún partido es salió como
ganador si después de estas
confrontaciones y creo que también hay
que aclarar acá muchas hablamos de una
guerra o de una confrontación pero
cuando hablamos de una guerra no sé yo
los latidos más o menos iguales parejos
no dos ejércitos o si hablamos de una
guerra civil entonces dos partidos más o
menos similares pero lo que fue el caso
acá por eso muchos también desde las
comunidades internacionales la prensa
internacional no hablo de una guerra
sino que hablo de genocidio si hablo de
masacre si hablo de matanza porque
realmente si uno compara el ejército del
gobierno israelí es tan avanzado uno de
los más avanzados y por otro lado
realmente están luchando los palestinos
con piedras con palos y ni siquiera
tiene un ejército oficial entonces
obviamente y creo que eso es lo más
triste que
las personas y eso hay que tener en
claro que eran civiles si ustedes
mencionaron varios números que tenemos
por ejemplo más de 230 víctimas por
parte de los palestinos y también
tenemos 12 civiles israelís y creo que
cada muerte es una tragedia en el isla
nosotros consideramos a sí incluso uno
mata a una persona inocente es como si
hubiera matado a toda la humanidad y
creo que eso es el precio que hemos
pagado recientemente como sociedades
como humanidad luego ni hablar de todos
los efectos que van a quedarse como
ellas si en particular en parte de casa
para entender gas tenemos en una parte
tan pequeña dos millones de habitantes y
casi 50% de ellos son menores de edad
entonces incluso según onu 1.4 millones
de los habitantes de gaza ya son
refugiados ya son desplazados ya
necesitan ayuda humanitaria médica
entonces obviamente ellos serían las
víctimas principales y ahora a pesar del
cese del fuego luego ellos seguirán con
el malestar con el sufrimiento con el
fracaso de los recursos básicos y en eso
creo que hemos pagado un precio muy alto
por este conflicto por esa escalada de
tensiones y también hay que tener en
cuenta a muchas veces hablamos de hamás
de hamás de sus reacciones y obviamente
yo como como representante de alguna
musulmana a mariah condenó cualquier
acto cualquier atentado contra civiles
sea por una parte un grupo terrorista un
grupo político o un estado oficial
cualquier atentado contra civiles
tenemos que condenarlo pero muchas es en
el conflicto palestino-israelí no
hablamos sobre los asuntos que llevaron
a tal reacción porque jamás lanzó
cohetes contra los civiles en israel no
hablamos sobre por ejemplo como el
estado de israel
constantemente el asentamiento ilegal o
también recientemente lo que todo lo que
ocurría en llegar a que otro proceso de
desalojar los palestinos que es una una
violación de las leyes internacionales
no hablamos que la policía durante el
mes de ramadán en uno de los lugares más
sagrados del islam en la mezquita de
al-aqsa y room dijo todo
y
aquí ponerlo en contexto por eso para
establecer la paz en esta parte
internamente o también de este la parte
la centralidad greenes internacional es
la clave es la justicia
la clave es la justicia recojo esa
palabra del señor wilson opinión señor
peckel en bogotá y mire primero que todo
eso es piedras y palos se parece una
fantasía vimos 4.000 cohetes de todo
tipo de alcance y sofisticación lanzados
a israel lo único que buscaba jamás era
matar civiles israelíes lo que pasa es
que israel si se preocupa por proteger a
su población en refugios antiaéreos y
con la interceptación de los misiles las
víctimas son una tragedia para todos
pero sin embargo para hamás las víctimas
las utiliza después como propaganda para
aparecer como la víctima pero tenemos
que entender también que que jamás se
mimetiza entre la población civil eso es
una clarísima violación al derecho
internacional que desde escuelas desde
edificios y residencias civiles y
barrios residenciales jamás ubica sus
lanzamientos lanzadores de cohetes para
desde allí atacar
a la población israel él entendía alemán
que justifica el lanzamiento de cohetes
por lo que israel hace yo no veo porque
yo expliqué que lo que ocurre en la
mezquita de al-aqsa que israel en
jerusalén en este siglo el único tiempo
en que ha habido libertad de cultos
absoluta ha sido desde que israel tiene
jerusalén en 1967 la mezquita de al-aqsa
y el domo de la roca que ser
administradas incluso por el rey por el
reino de jordania es un lugar donde
siempre se respeta el culto por lo tanto
a veces hay enfrentamientos a veces
comienza a lanzar desde ahí piedras a
los que están rezando en el muro de los
lamentos abajo pero es una actividad
recurrente ocurre con cierta frecuencia
no justifica de ninguna manera que hamás
que no son piedras y palos sino cohetes
que matan gente lanzará cohetes a
jerusalén y una cosa evidente que esta
vez varias cancillerías del mundo
su primera declaración fue condenado a
hamás lo hizo alemania lo hizo austria
louis o república checa lo hizo colombia
lo hizo la oea que condenó a hamás
porque la gente entiende que jamás para
avanzar sus designios políticos su
conflicto con la autoridad palestina no
tiene ningún inconveniente comenzar una
guerra como ésta y después sufrir las
consecuencias luego aparecer como
víctima como que tuvo las víctimas
normalmente israel cada cohete que la
anses adela gaza lo hace pensando la
evitar al máximo las víctimas civiles
pero hay momentos donde las víctimas
civiles se mimetizan en pro de la
población decir que lo que jamás hace
jamás se escuda detrás de la población
civil para atacar a israel y eso es
lamentable esos condenables y la
comunidad internacional ya lo está
entendiendo pero también la comunidad
internacional señor pgr critica mucho y
señala mucho israel
por este exceso de uso de la fuerza
militar por la capacidad militar que
tiene su ejército ya lo decía en uno de
los más avanzados del mundo también por
los excesos de los militares y
violaciones a los derechos humanos y en
esta ocasión el país no se escapó otra
vez de esas críticas
sí pero es que israel tiene armamento
muy sofisticado que le permite hacer
ataques quirúrgicos evitando al máximo
que mueran civiles en estos edificios
que están mostrando ahí mi ficción de
había cuarteles de hamás se le avisó a
la población antes que evacuará y cuando
el edificio cayó no causó víctimas por
lo tanto este armamento sofisticado del
que hablan le sirve a isla de
precisamente para eso mientras que hamás
es una organización terrorista que
quiere destruir a israel lo único que
hace es lanzar misiles a donde caigan
algunos apuntando bien y sus misiles de
esos cae en un lugar donde no no pudo
funcionar la interceptación donde no
fueron las sirenas la cantidad de
víctimas que tengais al pero para israel
la protección de su población está por
encima de todo eso no es lo mismo que
podemos decir de hamas
señor wiley hasta dónde puede llegar
entonces ese derecho de israel a
defenderse de estos ataques iniciados
por hamás ya lo decían más de 400
cohetes lanzados desde la franja de gaza
hacia 4000 poblaciones en israel donde
finaliza ese ese punto de capacidad de
defenderse por la fuerza y hacer valer
su territorio
y santiago que esto no es una muy buena
pregunta y para aclararlo la comemos
truman a maría que fue fundada en el año
1889 por el mesías prometido nosotros
categóricamente dice también para
aclararlo a nosotros categóricamente
condenamos cualquier acto de violencia o
terrorismo contra los civiles y no
hacemos ninguna distinción entre israelí
palestino judío musulmán cristiano ateo
sino que condenamos categóricamente
cualquier atentado o cualquier ataque
cualquier lanzamiento de cohete contra
civiles y eso en una forma igual y para
todos
decir eso también ahora para ponerlo en
contexto él no se puede poner en una
proporción si el estado 16 si nosotros
hablamos de todas las confrontaciones
del pasado sea hora del año 2014 2012
2008 siempre pagaron el precio de estas
confrontaciones los civiles y más
siempre por la parte de los palestinos
entonces no hay ninguna proporción entre
la reacción de a hamás y luego la
reacción violenta agresiva del estado
israel por ejemplo ahora también los
números tenemos 240 víctimas palestinos
entre ellos 65 o más de 60 niños
por otro lado obviamente lamentó también
los 12 muertos o 2 muertes de israelís
pero incluso por ejemplo la última
confrontación en 2014 tuvimos por parte
palestina más de 2.000 víctimas y por
parte de israel
más o menos 70 personas entonces no hay
ninguna proporción la venganza por parte
del estado israelí siempre tan
es mucho más grave que el delito
original y eso vimos también ahora
obviamente hay que condenar cualquier
atentado por parte de hamás pero no se
puede justificar en ninguna forma ni
siquiera por supuestamente la propia
defensa la matanza la masacre de vidas
inocentes tenemos el testimonio del
directors male de una organización de
onu y justo da ayuda apoyo humanitario
en gaza y él dice que el estado de
israel incluso ahora recibió la ayuda
médica para civiles sí y el público y es
totalmente abiertamente registrado e
incluso los llama server from the sky
una forma de terrorismo luego tenemos
por ejemplo las aclaraciones de human
rights watch que no es así como que ahí
hay igualdad para todos en israel human
rights watch que no es una organización
humanitaria o no tiene ninguna no tiene
ninguna bandera política es una
organización no gubernamental y ellos
incluso usan las palabras apretadas usan
las palabras persecución contra árabes
usan las palabras ataques contra civiles
hablan usan las palabras de una fuerza
excesiva contra los palestinos luego
tenemos incluso una
a agencia israelí por derechos humanos
betselem erwin ellos mismos denuncian al
estado de israel y usan la palabra
aperta e incluso hablan de crímenes de
guerra en gaza entonces mientras tenemos
tantas organizaciones humanitarias no
gubernamentales denunciando el estado
israelí entonces por su agresión
exagerada hacia civiles en eso creo que
aclarar también como que el el líder al
jalifa espiritual de la cuna musulmana
ahmadía que no hay ninguna proporción
entre las agresiones o los ataques de
hamas y luego las reacciones por parte
del gobierno de israel sí
señor pequeño pues puede no entender
desde la perspectiva de israel ese
derecho a este país a defenderse de
todas las agresiones que pueda recibir
por entonces dónde quedan los canales
diplomáticos dónde quedan las
organizaciones internacionales en esos
países aliados que pueden servir para
conversar y evitar estas escaladas de
tensión en un futuro pues los canales
diplomáticos siempre ha estado dispuesto
y se ha estado dispuesto a hacer la paz
con los palestinos israel hizo la paz
con conversa después de disparar también
cohetes o no no no es que hoy aire para
atrás de los cohetes no los lanza y sal
porque decide lanzar israel reacciona
ante agresiones de una organización
terrorista que no que desalojó de gasa
el gobierno legítimamente constituido la
autoridad palestina pero esa el negocio
los acuerdos de oslo con yaser arafat
recordemos y cuando llegó el momento
definitivo de cerrar el conflicto
palestino-israelí que saliera a la
agenda internacional el año 2000 en la
cumbre tan débil con el presidente
clinton el presidente clinton puso un
acuerdo de paz sobre la mesa
muy concreto muy claro se creaba un
estado palestino independiente al lado
de israel jerusalén será la capital de
ambos estados y si la idea fin al
conflicto israel aceptó
la propuesta de paz de clinton y yasser
arafat no yaser arafat no la aceptó
yasser arafat abrió las cárceles de de
los territorios palestinos liberó a los
señores de hamás y miré con quién
estamos hablando
hamas es una organización que entre el
año 2000 y el 2004 envió centenares de
adolescentes niñas de 15 18 20 años a
inmolarse en israel a acabar su vida que
recién empezaba con el único objetivo de
matar judíos y con eso matar el acuerdo
de paz es que es con esto con lo que se
está lidiando una organización que manda
un niño de 20 años a que se inmola en un
supermercado en israel o que symbol en
una universidad o en una discoteca
es infame eso es con lo que se está
enfrentando esos señores de hamás son
los culpables de la situación de los
palestinos en gaza nadie más si ellos
empiezan una guerra israel tiene que
reaccionar no hay nada que hacer y eso
está amparable el derecho internacional
el derecho a la legítima defensa y ya y
eso lo que ha ocurrido en el 2008 lo que
ocurrió en el 2012 en el 2014 y ahora
esperemos que no haya otra ronda pero si
jamás sigue gobernando gaza va a haber
otra ronda
me quedan ya pocos minutos para terminar
el programa quiero plantearle el
escenario futuro lo que viene de aquí en
adelante claramente el señor pequeño se
mantiene esa atención allí entre las
partes se mantiene la atención del medio
oriente después de estos diez días de
confrontaciones entre hamás y el
ejército de israel y también queda sobre
la mesa la situación sanitaria la que
queda gaza con una infraestructura
afectada con muchas personas desplazadas
en medio de la pandemia de kobe 19
israel ha sido líder en el tema de la
vacunación y sus ciudadanos están un
poco más seguros pero
los palestinos y en particular los que
están allí recibiendo en casa no han
recibido todas las vacunas incluso
israel fue criticado a nivel
internacional por no permitir el rápido
acceso de vacunas a esos territorios
como ve usted entonces el escenario a
futuro pero como va a haber vacunas en
casa si los señores de hamás gasta la
plata en cohetes de hamas gasta la plata
en infraestructura bélica esa plata que
puede ser para vacunas para la para
enfrentar la pandemia lo están usando en
otra cosa
israel no ha impedido al trabajo unas
cuentas y jordania que es la otra parte
de palestina de donde israel incluso le
ha donado los primeros vacunados en
cisjordania pero con vacunas que no
israel a la autoridad palestina para su
personal médico ya que acá la pandemia
y si usted dice porque en gaza las la
gente vive así porque en casa no hay
agua porque en casa no hay posibilidades
porque hamás toda la planta que dentro
de la casa para que vimos los cohetes
fueron 4.000 cohetes cuánto valen 4.000
cohetes de esos que mandaron cuánto
valen los lanzadores es esa plata se
pudo haber utilizaban vacunas para la
población de gaza
pero no señor de hamás no permiten eso
ellos son los que gobiernan ahí escrito
una organización que no tiene ninguna
ningún cuidado por sus habitantes no le
interesa le interesa la guerra con
israel sus habitantes los utiliza para
propaganda los utiliza como escudos y no
los vacuna y después culpa israel de que
no entraron vacunas gasten la plata en
vacunas no empiecen guerras con israel y
así va a poder superar el tema la
pandemia en gas hermano conclusión
entonces escenario bélico a futuro
claramente de acuerdo a lo que usted
explica con hamás y la franja de gaza
el señor wil su opinión sobre el
escenario fiebres si yo creo que para
que haya realmente paz y para que
realmente resolver ese conflicto
hay que establecer y hay que poner la
justicia como la prioridad como la ley
mientras no haya justicia por parte de
las comunidades internacionales no
podemos esperar un cambio en ese
conflicto es solamente a postergarlo
hasta la próxima confrontación violenta
inició creo que es muy
de que ahora incluso ahora perdimos o
tardamos de perder más de 200 vidas
civiles y luego llegamos al sexo del
fuego y creo que muy triste muy doloroso
incluso a pesar de eso tardaron muchos
países tanto en condenar el estado
israel condenaron directamente la el
lanzamiento de cohetes por parte de
hamás pero no no condenaron las mismas
cohetes contra civiles en gaza por parte
del estado israelí y eso creo que no es
el criterio de justicia el sagrado corán
enseña que para establecer la justicia
en sociedad el criterio fundamental es
justicia incluso si uno tiene que
testificar contra su propia persona
contra sus propios familiares y eso es
lo que no vemos
en él por las comunidades
internacionales por otro lado creo
también para asegurar el bienestar la
convivencia la armonía entre los
diferentes grupos en esa zona hay que
asegurar también la igualdad
internamente si el profeta mohamed la
paz
y estable un árabe no tiene ninguna
superioridad sobre no árabe ni un hombre
blanco sobre un hombre negro y creo que
eso hay que implementar que ningún judío
tenga su prioridad sobre un no judío así
mismo que ningún musulmán tenga
superioridad sobre un no musulmán sino
que todos no rindan los mismos derechos
y retomando lo que usted dice de
justicia entonces sería lo que se
tendría que ver en ese escenario futuro
ante una posible escalada allí en medio
oriente en marcos peckel en la ciudad de
bogotá imán marwan willy en la ciudad de
buenos aires- muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el debate de
france 24 ya veremos el desenlace de
toda esta historia y a ustedes pues los
invito para que sigan dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales siguen con la
programación de france 24 gracias
[Música]